Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. That night, as Hernan Cortes stood on his balcony and stared out across the lights of the city, his mind was uneasy. To seek his fortune, he had travelled thousands of miles across land and sea, and here he was, in the centre of an island city, in the heart of a foreign empire, surrounded by people who didn't speak his language, didn't worship his god, and could turn on him at any moment. And as a deep silence fell across the city, one thought preyed on his mind. So far,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。那天晚上，埃尔南·科尔特斯站在阳台上，凝视着城市里的灯火，心中感到不安。为了寻求财富，他跨越千山万水，远渡重洋，而现在，他身处一座岛屿城市的中心，置身于一个异国帝国的腹地，周围的人说着他听不懂的语言，不信奉他的神，而且随时可能对他倒戈相向。当城市陷入深沉的寂静时，一个念头在他脑海中挥之不去。到目前为止，
he had been lucky, but one day, very soon, his luck might run out. Thrilling stuff there, Dominic, from your new book, The Fall of the Aztecs, one of your Adventures in Time series. Great stuff. And we are, what is this? I'm losing track. Episode four? Episode four, Tom. Into our Aztec epic.
他一直很幸运，但总有一天，很快，他的好运可能会用尽。多米尼克，你那本新书《阿兹特克人的陨落》（The Fall of the Aztecs）里的内容真是扣人心弦，这是你“时间冒险”（Adventures in Time）系列的一部分。太棒了。我们现在是在，这是什么？我有点记不清了。第四集？第四集，汤姆。进入我们的阿兹特克史诗。
And Cortes and his Spanish adventurers are in Tenochtitlan, the great Aztec capital, and what is going to happen next? Well, this is the question, isn't it, Tom? Because this thought must have been on their minds. Yeah. I mean, how could it not be? Cortes, just to recap, has made this extraordinary gamble. He has gone against his orders with this company, many of whom are probably not particularly loyal to him and have their own agendas. They have gone inland, as we discussed last time. They seem to have struck this alliance with a city-state called Tlaxcala. And then they've gone across the causeway. They've been welcomed by the Mexica, by their emperor Montezuma or
科尔特斯和他的西班牙冒险家们身处伟大的阿兹特克首都特诺奇蒂特兰，接下来会发生什么呢？嗯，这就是问题所在，不是吗，汤姆？因为这个念头一定在他们脑海中盘旋。是的。我的意思是，怎么可能不在呢？科尔特斯，简单回顾一下，他进行了一场非凡的赌博。他违抗了命令，带着这群人，其中许多人可能对他并不特别忠诚，而且各有各的算盘。正如我们上次讨论的那样，他们深入了内陆。他们似乎与一个叫特拉斯卡拉的城邦结成了联盟。然后他们穿过了堤道。他们受到了墨西加人，也就是他们的皇帝蒙特祖马或
Moctezuma or whatever one might call him. And they've been welcomed. They've been welcomed by the Mexica, by their emperor Montezuma or Moctezuma or whatever one might call him. And they've been welcomed. They've been installed in the palace in the center of the kind of big ceremonial temple quarter. And what is going on? I mean, the truth of the matter, of course, they don't know. They don't speak the language. They're entirely reliant on Malinche, this former slave girl, to translate for them. But actually, I think in the first few
莫克特祖马，或者随便你怎么称呼他，他们的欢迎。他们受到了欢迎。他们受到了墨西加人，也就是他们的皇帝蒙特祖马或莫克特祖马，或者随便你怎么称呼他，他们的欢迎。他们受到了欢迎。他们被安置在大型礼仪神庙区中心的一座宫殿里。到底发生了什么？我的意思是，事实当然是，他们不知道。他们不会说当地语言。他们完全依赖马林切，这个曾经的奴隶女孩，为他们翻译。但实际上，我认为在最初的几天里，
days, they're probably quite relieved because they have servants to wait on them. Bernal Diaz, all these sources are very suspect, but he's our best source. And he sort of says, there are people there with tortillas and with bits of turkey and chocolate and corn and these kinds of things. And actually, it's fine. I mean, you say they don't know what's going on. Important to emphasise at this point that actually historians can't be certain what's going on as well. So this is a further dimension to the mystery, as we will come to, that actually the sources for this are treacherous in so many ways.
他们可能感到相当宽慰，因为有仆人伺候他们。贝尔纳·迪亚斯，所有这些资料来源都非常可疑，但他确实是我们最好的来源。他大概是说，那里有人带着玉米饼、火鸡肉、巧克力和玉米之类的东西。实际上，这还不错。我的意思是，你说他们不知道发生了什么。此时必须强调的是，实际上历史学家们也无法确定到底发生了什么。所以这是这个谜团的另一个维度，正如我们稍后会提到的，实际上关于此事的史料在许多方面都是不可靠的。
Very treacherous in so many ways. Very treacherous. Yeah. And as a result, there are actually lots of quite opposed theories as to what happens in the days and then the weeks and months that follow. So we should look at that. But I think one thing that is absolutely clear is that the Spaniards would have been completely blown away. I mean, we keep harking back to science fiction. This is the equivalent to Captain Kirk beaming down and finding himself in the middle of some spectacular galactic space scape. Except that it's on the face of the earth. They crossed the oceans and found this stunning, stunning city. Yeah, you're right. The science fiction parallel is a good one because so much science fiction
在许多方面都非常不可靠。非常不可靠。是的。因此，关于接下来的几天、几周和几个月里发生了什么，实际上存在许多截然不同的理论。所以我们应该看看这一点。但我认为有一点是绝对清楚的，那就是西班牙人一定会被彻底震撼。我的意思是，我们一直在引用科幻小说。这相当于柯克船长降落并发现自己置身于某种壮观的银河系空间景观中。只不过这是在地球表面。他们跨越了海洋，发现了这座令人惊叹的城市。是的，你说得对。科幻小说的类比很恰当，因为太多的科幻小说
is clearly based on these sort of European encounters with indigenous people. The remarkable thing is that, as we said before, the Aztec or the Mexica civilization is, what would you call it, Tom, a kind of Bronze Age civilization, I suppose? Yeah. They don't have steel swords. They're about the level of what? Camilla Tenzin compares it to the Sumerians. The Sumerians, yeah. So it's kind of the early Mesopotamian civilizations. So it's a sophisticated urban civilization, but technologically it is, as it were,
显然是基于这种欧洲人与原住民的接触。值得注意的事情是，正如我们之前所说，阿兹特克或墨西加文明是，你会怎么称呼它，汤姆，一种青铜时代文明，我想？是的。他们没有钢剑。他们大约处于什么水平？卡米拉·汤森将其比作苏美尔人。苏美尔人，是的。所以这是一种早期的美索不达米亚文明。所以它是一个复杂的城市文明，但在技术上，它是，怎么说呢，
if you want to think of it this way, behind the old world. And yet, Tenochtitlan is a much bigger city than anything they have seen in Europe. As we were saying before, the sort of metro area, it's probably got a million people in it. It's also, they say straight away, it's astonishing to them how well-ordered, how regimented, how well-maintained, how clean. Yeah, because it's new, isn't it? So unlike Rome or Paris, where the streets have grown up over many, many centuries, this is much more like an American city, a modern American city, kind of grid systems and laid out like that. It has shops more like an American city, a modern American city, kind of grid systems and laid out like that. It has shops though, which American cities of course don't, if you're
如果你想这样看的话，落后于旧世界。然而，特诺奇蒂特兰是一座比他们在欧洲见过的任何城市都要大得多的城市。正如我们之前所说，大都市区可能有一百万人。而且，他们立刻就说，它秩序井然、管理严密、维护良好、干净整洁，这让他们感到震惊。是的，因为它是新的，不是吗？所以不像罗马或巴黎，那里的街道是经过许多世纪发展起来的，这更像是一座美国城市，一座现代美国城市，有网格系统，布局就是那样。它有商店，
branded out as American shops. So it doesn't have shopping malls, although it does have floating gardens, which is nice. Yeah. And I think I suppose the difference, it's not as chaotic as it, as a European city, as Seville, where many of them would have sailed from. You know, Seville is an old city and had recently, relatively recently anyway, been retaken from the Moors. So there's a jumble of different influences in Seville, whereas somewhere like Tenochtitlan is probably much more uniform.
如果把美国商店作为品牌的话。所以它没有购物中心，尽管它有浮动花园，这很不错。是的，我想区别在于，它不像欧洲城市，不像塞维利亚，他们中的许多人就是从那里启航的，那样混乱。你知道，塞维利亚是一座古老的城市，而且相对较近的时候才从摩尔人手中夺回。所以塞维利亚有各种不同影响的混合体，而像特诺奇蒂特兰这样的地方可能要统一得多。
You've got the Great Pyramids, but also it's so regimented. So it's divided into quadrants and each quadrant is divided into neighborhoods and there are different kinds of officials who supervise the different neighborhoods and things and everybody has their place and to go against the expectations of society of your world is kind of unthinkable there's no evidence that people really did it and in a sense i think even though it's a sort of bronze age
你有大金字塔，但它也非常严整。所以它被划分为象限，每个象限又被划分为社区，有不同类型的官员监督不同的社区等等，每个人都有自己的位置，违背社会或你所在世界的期望在那里是不可想象的，没有证据表明人们真的那样做过，在某种意义上，我认为即使它是一种青铜时代
civilization that clearly is a very powerful apparatus of kind of state regimentation. So they go, for example, to this huge market at Tlatelolco, which is another island kind of connected with Tenochtitlan, like a kind of suburb basically. And they go to the market where you can buy everything. You can buy all these amazing things that they've never seen before, the chocolate and the spices and chilies and feathers. Quetzal feathers. Right, exactly. Feathers and all these things. But Bernardia says the thing that really is striking to them is how regimented it is, how well-ordered, how there are officials everywhere
文明，显然它拥有一种非常强大的国家管理机制。所以，例如，他们去了特拉特洛尔科的这个巨大市场，这是另一个与特诺奇蒂特兰相连的岛屿，基本上就像一个郊区。他们去了市场，在那里你可以买到一切。你可以买到所有这些他们从未见过的神奇东西，巧克力、香料、辣椒和羽毛。格查尔鸟的羽毛。对，没错。羽毛和所有这些东西。但贝尔纳·迪亚斯说，真正让他们震惊的是它管理得多么严密，多么井然有序，到处都有官员
to sort of regulate the weights and measures and all these kinds of things. And this is very Moctezuma, isn't it? He seems to have been very into this, the idea that this state that has emerged very, very recently should be set on a firm organizational footing. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. So there's that. That amazes them.
来规范度量衡和所有这些事情。这非常像蒙特祖马，不是吗？他似乎非常热衷于此，认为这个刚刚兴起的国家应该建立在稳固的组织基础上。是的，绝对是。绝对是。所以就是这样。这让他们感到惊奇。
But also, as you say, the sheer science fiction kind of culture shock. So Cortez says in one of his letters at one point, it was all so wondrous that we could barely believe it. Another of his comrades says the city was a place of enchantment. We were never sure whether it was real or if we were dreaming. And as we said before, they've come having read all these chivalric romances and suddenly they're in one. I suppose the equivalence is like an astronaut who's grown up with Star Wars and Star Trek and all of these things. And then he lands on an alien planet and it's just like,
但正如你所说，还有那种纯粹的科幻式的文化冲击。所以科尔特斯在其中一封信中曾说，这一切都太奇妙了，我们几乎不敢相信。他的另一位战友说，这座城市是一个充满魔力的地方。我们从不确定它是真实的，还是我们在做梦。正如我们之前所说，他们读过所有这些骑士传奇，突然间他们就置身于其中了。我想这相当于一个从小看着《星球大战》和《星际迷航》长大的宇航员。然后他降落在一个外星行星上，就像，
you know, there are people with three heads, kind of bustling bazaars and amazing towers and things. Yeah. And I think that that kind of sense the Spaniards convey of entering a dreamscape hangs over the whole historiography of it as well. Yeah. Because the sense of the greatest culture clash, perhaps in the history of human civilization, it's difficult for all of us to get a handle on. Yeah.
你知道，有长着三个头的人，熙熙攘攘的集市和令人惊叹的塔楼之类的东西。是的。而且我认为西班牙人传达的那种进入梦境的感觉也笼罩了整个相关的史学研究。是的。因为这种人类文明史上或许最伟大的文化冲突，我们所有人都很难把握。是的。
Because it's gone. Tenochtitlan has gone. Yeah. And so it's difficult for us to get back to a sense of what it must have been like. And the only way that we can really do it is through the eyes of the Spaniards. Because the Spaniards are the embodiment of the culture that is coming. And the most arresting moment from Bernal Diaz's account of these early days is when they go to the Great Temple. Now you said Tenochtitlan is gone, but I was in Mexico City earlier this year
因为它消失了。特诺奇蒂特兰消失了。是的。所以我们很难回到那种身临其境的感觉。我们唯一能真正做到的方式就是通过西班牙人的眼睛。因为西班牙人是即将到来的文化的化身。贝尔纳·迪亚斯对这些早期的描述中最引人注目的时刻是他们去大神庙的时候。现在你说特诺奇蒂特兰消失了，但我今年早些时候在墨西哥城
and went to the Great Temple, the ruins of the Great Temple. It's still, even the ruins are a remarkable historical site. And I have to say the museum is absolutely brilliant. It really is. And Bernardi's account of when they go to that temple, I mean, unlike me, they don't know what to expect. I'd been primed for it for years of reading about the Aztecs since I was a little boy. They're not primed at all. The sheer size of it, I think 114 steps and this sort of stepped pyramid, they go up to the top.
去了大神庙，大神庙的遗址。即使是遗址，它仍然是一个非凡的历史遗迹。我必须说博物馆绝对精彩。确实如此。贝尔纳·迪亚斯对他们去那座神庙的描述，我的意思是，不像我，他们不知道会发生什么。我从小就读过关于阿兹特克人的书，对此早有准备。他们根本没有准备。我想它的规模之大，114级台阶和这种阶梯金字塔，他们爬到了顶端。
And one of the early afternoons, it's Montezuma's officials who lead Cortes and his men up to the top. The emperor is already up there sort of doing some sacrifices or whatever. So they go up there to the 11. The emperor is already up there doing some sacrifices or whatever. So they go up there to the 114th step. And you can imagine the scene that they now have the view over the whole city, over the lake. They can see the order of it. They can see the size. Just an incredible scene. Bernardier says some of his companions who had been to Constantinople and Rome and traveled through the whole of Italy. Of course, they've traveled through Italy because they've probably been mercenaries or merchants,
在其中一个下午，是蒙特祖马的官员带领科尔特斯和他的手下爬到顶端的。皇帝已经在上面做一些祭祀之类的活动了。所以他们爬到了第114级台阶。你可以想象他们现在的场景，他们俯瞰整个城市，俯瞰湖泊。他们可以看到它的秩序。他们可以看到它的规模。真是一个不可思议的场景。贝尔纳·迪亚斯说，他的一些同伴曾去过君士坦丁堡和罗马，游历过整个意大利。当然，他们游历过意大利，因为他们可能是雇佣兵或商人，
or they've been involved in the many Italian wars in the early 16th century. And they say, God, this is incredible. I've never been anywhere like this. But then there's this absolutely extraordinary culture clash scene. If you believe Bernal Diaz's account, and I'd see no reason to disbelieve this,
或者他们参与了16世纪初的许多意大利战争。他们说，天哪，这太不可思议了。我从未去过这样的地方。但随后出现了这个绝对非凡的文化冲突场景。如果你相信贝尔纳·迪亚斯的叙述，而且我看不到不相信的理由，
Cortes says to the emperor, to Montezuma, I'd love to see your gods. And Montezuma takes him in to the shrine, which is on the top of this temple. So it's a double pyramid. And one of the shrines is to the god Huitzilopochtli. He's their patron, isn't it? He's their patron. That's exactly the word I was looking for. When they reinvented their own history, they claimed they were his kind of chosen people yeah and an amazing scene bernal diaz description they go in
科尔特斯对皇帝，对蒙特祖马说，我很想看看你们的神。蒙特祖马带他进入了神庙顶部的神龛。所以这是一座双重金字塔。其中一个神龛是供奉战神维齐洛波奇特利的。他是他们的守护神，对吧？他是他们的守护神。那正是我想找的词。当他们重塑自己的历史时，他们声称自己是他的选民，是的，一个惊人的场景，贝尔纳·迪亚斯的描述，他们进去了
and they can't really see anything because it's dark and then they see the statue of huitzilopochtli with distorted and furious looking eyes covered all over with jewels and pearls and bernal diaz describes him covered with kind of stone writhing serpents and there are carved sort of human faces hanging from his neck and next to him is another sort of idol which looks like half a man and half a lizard and it looks like it's been made of seeds or something that have been stuck together with human blood yeah so at this point, the Spaniards are clearly thinking, oh God, this is pungent stuff. Well, probably what they're thinking is that they're thinking of descriptions of the idols and blood sacrifice in the Bible. Yeah, well, that would be where
因为光线昏暗，他们看不清什么，然后他们看到了维齐洛波奇特利的雕像，眼睛扭曲而愤怒，全身覆盖着珠宝和珍珠，贝尔纳·迪亚斯描述他身上覆盖着某种石雕的蜿蜒蛇，脖子上挂着雕刻的人脸，在他旁边是另一个偶像，看起来像半人半蜥蜴，看起来像是用种子之类的东西粘在一起的，上面还有人血，是的，所以此时，西班牙人显然在想，天哪，这东西太刺鼻了。嗯，他们可能在想的是圣经中关于偶像和血祭的描述。是的，好吧，那会是
they would have, yeah. And so they would have no doubt that these are statues of demons. That seems totally plausible. I mean, that must be the one place where you read about idols or other gods. That is the, you know, you talked about chivalric romances, but now they would feel like they're walking into the Old Testament. Yeah. Would be my guess. Well, especially what they see next, because then, according to the account, if you take the account in sort of chronological order, Bernard Dias says they see braziers, three braziers, in which are smouldering these kind of blackened lumps of flesh,
他们会有的，是的。所以他们会毫不怀疑这些是恶魔的雕像。这看起来完全合理。我的意思是，那一定是你读到偶像或其他神灵的唯一地方。那就是，你知道，你谈到了骑士传奇，但现在他们会感觉自己走进了《旧约》。是的，我会这样猜测。嗯，尤其是他们接下来看到的东西，因为根据叙述，如果你按时间顺序看，贝尔纳·迪亚斯说他们看到了火盆，三个火盆，里面闷烧着那种发黑的肉块，
and they peer into the braziers and they realise they're, or they think they're seeing human hearts. And Bernal Diaz says, every wall was black and clotted with human blood and the stench was worse than in a Spanish slaughterhouse. It was so abominable that we could hardly wait to get away. Now, there'll be some people listening to this who say, how much is this propaganda, orientalizing propaganda? Right. Because if you're expecting the Old Testament, this is what you would expect to see. Yeah. But we do know that they, I mean, we talked about this with Camilla Townsend. We know that the Mexica did carry out human sacrifices, probably not quite on the scale that Spaniards claimed. But human sacrifice was undoubtedly a part of their religious rituals,
他们盯着火盆看，意识到，或者他们认为他们看到了人心。贝尔纳·迪亚斯说，每一面墙都漆黑一片，凝结着人血，恶臭比西班牙的屠宰场还要严重。这太令人厌恶了，我们几乎迫不及待地想离开。现在，会有一些听众说，这有多少是宣传，东方主义的宣传？对。因为如果你期待的是《旧约》，这正是你所期望看到的。是的。但我们确实知道他们，我的意思是，我们和卡米拉·汤森谈过这个。我们知道墨西加人确实进行了人祭，可能规模没有西班牙人声称的那么大。但人祭无疑是他们宗教仪式的一部分，
wasn't it, Tom? Absolutely. And I think that to imagine that this is ipso facto a bad thing is to reflect the Christian assumptions of the Spaniards. If you're saying, they must have just made this up because human sacrifice is so evidently evil and wrong, then that is fundamentally a Christian perspective. You've got to try and think outside that box. Because there are reasons why the Mexica are doing it that make perfect sense in the context of their understanding of the cosmos. That if blood is not spilled, then the universe will come to an end. Yeah, that's undoubtedly what they think, isn't it?
不是吗，汤姆？绝对是。而且我认为，认为这本身就是一件坏事，反映了西班牙人的基督教假设。如果你说，他们一定是编造了这个，因为人祭显然是邪恶和错误的，那么这从根本上就是一种基督教视角。你必须尝试跳出那个框框去思考。因为墨西加人这样做是有原因的，在他们对宇宙的理解背景下，这些原因完全说得通。如果血不流出来，那么宇宙就会终结。是的，毫无疑问他们是这样想的，不是吗？
In her book, Fifth Sun, Camilla Townsend is brilliant on this, on the way in which they think the cosmology works. The sun rises and falls, and it's actually the constant flow of blood that keeps it going. It's kind of like net zero. Unless you do it, the planet will end. My word. It will be engulfed by fire. That is not a comparison I expected. But I think that that's the kind of comparison that you have to understand to understand why
在她的书《第五个太阳》（Fifth Sun）中，卡米拉·汤森对此进行了精彩的论述，关于他们认为宇宙学是如何运作的。太阳升起又落下，实际上是血液的不断流动维持着它。这有点像净零排放。除非你这样做，否则地球就会终结。天哪。它会被大火吞没。这不是我预料到的比较。但我认为这就是你必须理解的比较，才能理解为什么
they're doing it, is that they feel that they're faced by the ruin of the planet if they don't do it. Right. I mean, they're not doing it out of pure sadism. No, they're not doing it because they're evil or cruel. Yeah. They're doing it for deeply held reasons. Yes. Yeah.
他们这样做，是因为他们觉得如果不这样做，他们就会面临地球的毁灭。对。我的意思是，他们这样做不是出于纯粹的虐待狂。不，他们这样做不是因为他们邪恶或残忍。是的。他们这样做是有深层原因的。是的。是的。
Well, you see, so there's an exchange now recorded by Bernard Diaz, which I think rings absolutely true. Cortes, by the way, he's coming more and more into focus, I think, as the journey goes on. His character, which is quite obscure when he's out there in the Caribbean or when he's in Spain, now we see more of him and he's an extraordinary opportunist. But just because he's opportunistic and ruthless later on doesn't mean that he doesn't have deeply held convictions. And so when he says to Montezuma, I think he does say this and I think he means it. He says to him, I don't understand why such a wise king hasn't realized that these idols are not gods, they are dev devils and i really hope you will allow us to
嗯，你看，贝尔纳·迪亚斯记录了一次交流，我认为这听起来绝对真实。顺便说一句，随着旅程的进行，科尔特斯越来越清晰地出现在我们面前。他的性格，当他在加勒比海或西班牙时相当模糊，现在我们看到了更多，他是一个非凡的机会主义者。但仅仅因为他后来投机取巧且冷酷无情，并不意味着他没有根深蒂固的信念。所以当他对蒙特祖马说时，我想他确实说了，而且我认为他是认真的。他对他说，我不明白为什么这样一位睿智的国王还没有意识到这些偶像不是神，它们是恶魔，我真的希望你能允许我们
put up a christian cross and then cortez says slightly boastfully when we do put up the christian cross your gods will quail in terror because they are nothing but demons absolutely no reason to believe that cortez wouldn't have thought that very sincerely. And then Montezuma, he is really offended. He's outraged. And he says to him, if I had known that you would say something so dishonorable, I would never have shown you our gods. They bring us health and life, crops and rain, and they bring us victory. Never talk about my gods in this way again. Well, I mean, imagine a load of Aztecs turn up in Seville and say, you've got to get rid of that guy on the cross and put up a statue of Wistel Potchley. Yeah, yes.
竖起一个十字架，然后科尔特斯稍微吹嘘地说，当我们竖起十字架时，你们的神会因恐惧而颤抖，因为它们不过是恶魔。绝对没有理由相信科尔特斯不会真诚地那样想。然后蒙特祖马，他真的被冒犯了。他很愤怒。他对他说，如果我知道你会说出如此不光彩的话，我绝不会让你看我们的神。它们带给我们健康和生命、庄稼和雨水，它们带给我们胜利。永远不要再这样谈论我的神了。嗯，我的意思是，想象一下一群阿兹特克人出现在塞维利亚，说，你必须摆脱十字架上的那个人，竖起维齐洛波奇特利的雕像。是的，没错。
That wouldn't go down well at all, would it? No, it's exactly the same. I think Montezuma is pretty restrained, all things considered. Yeah, because they then go away and he says, I have to stay up here and basically I now have to make penance for the abysmal, the appalling way in which you have spoken about my gods. And that whole exchange, I think, is absolutely... I mean, there are many things in the standard story that are implausible.
那根本行不通，不是吗？不，完全一样。考虑到所有因素，我认为蒙特祖马已经相当克制了。是的，因为他们随后离开了，他说，我必须留在这里，基本上我现在必须为你们谈论我的神的方式所犯下的滔天大罪进行忏悔。而整个交流，我认为，绝对是……我的意思是，标准故事中有很多事情是不可信的。
That exchange seems to me immensely plausible. And actually, in a way, you could say it's quite gutsy of Cortes to say it, but also culturally insensitive, Tom. But let's put it this way, that even if it didn't, even if he didn't say it, Diaz is undoubtedly articulating what Cortés probably thought. So he may be dramatizing something that didn't happen. Yeah. Yeah, that's a fair point.
那次交流在我看来非常可信。而且实际上，你可以说科尔特斯说出这些话很有胆量，但也缺乏文化敏感性，汤姆。但让我们这样说，即使它没有发生，即使他没说，迪亚斯无疑是在表达科尔特斯可能想到的东西。所以他可能是在戏剧化一些没有发生的事情。是的。是的，这很有道理。
But Cortés must have thought that. He must have done. He must have done. And it must have been obvious to the Mexica that their guests were hugely discomforted. Because this is the one thing the Mexica understand about the Spaniards is that they are very, very devoted to their God. Yeah. I mean, that's how they come to define them, I think. Yes. So there's one historian we've mentioned, I think once or twice, Fernandez Cervantes, who wrote a book called Conquistadores. And as I said,
但科尔特斯一定想过。他一定想过。他一定想过。而且对于墨西加人来说，他们的客人感到非常不舒服一定很明显。因为这是墨西加人对西班牙人唯一理解的一点，那就是他们对他们的上帝非常非常虔诚。是的。我的意思是，我认为这就是他们定义他们的方式。是的。所以有一位历史学家我们提到过，我想是一两次，费尔南德斯·塞万提斯，他写了一本名为《征服者》（Conquistadores）的书。正如我所说，
I think previously, this is music to your ears, Tom. He says, you will not understand anything that happens if you think the Spanish are just greedy and violent. You have to understand that they genuinely believe that the Mexica are doing something absolutely terrible by not following the one God, and that we're more tolerant that we have a kind of broader understanding of the diversity of opinions across the world i mean are you in favor of human sacrifice is the question well yes so we'll be coming on to this the weird thing is we're doing these episodes but we're also in the middle of preparing some episodes about captain cook another very different personification of european very different and oddly enough the same issue comes up with captain cook doesn't it anyway to go back to Cook, another very different personification of European colonialism. And oddly enough, the same issue comes up with Captain Cook, doesn't it? Anyway, to go back to the relationship, that key relationship between Cortez and Montezuma,
我想之前，这对你来说是天籁之音，汤姆。他说，如果你认为西班牙人只是贪婪和暴力，你就不会理解发生的任何事情。你必须明白，他们真诚地相信，墨西加人因为不追随唯一的上帝而做着绝对可怕的事情，而且我们更宽容，我们对世界各地观点的多样性有更广泛的理解，我的意思是，你支持人祭吗，这是个问题，嗯，是的，所以我们稍后会谈到这一点，奇怪的是，我们正在制作这些剧集，但我们同时也正在准备一些关于库克船长的剧集，另一个非常不同的欧洲化身，非常不同，奇怪的是，同样的问题也出现在库克船长身上，不是吗？无论如何，回到库克，另一个非常不同的欧洲殖民主义化身。奇怪的是，同样的问题也出现在库克船长身上，不是吗？无论如何，回到这种关系，科尔特斯和蒙特祖马之间那种关键的关系，
I think their relationship seems to have been pretty good, actually, given how suspicious they are of each other and all the possibilities for- They're kind of, they're scoping each other out, aren't they? They are, yeah. Montezuma has them for dinner. Bernal Diaz has these lovely passages about all the fancy things they eat. They would have smoked tobacco with him because that was a Mexica kind of pastime. They're clearly given guided tours. I know you love a guided tour, Tom. I love a guided tour. Yeah. They're given guided tours. Especially if it's coming from the emperor himself. Yeah. Well, I mean, he has the amazing palace complex where he would have his records, the kind of painted books.
我认为他们的关系似乎相当不错，实际上，考虑到他们彼此之间是多么怀疑，以及所有可能发生的——他们是在互相试探，不是吗？他们是，是的。蒙特祖马请他们吃饭。贝尔纳·迪亚斯有一些关于他们吃的所有精美食物的可爱段落。他们会和他一起抽烟草，因为那是墨西加人的一种消遣。他们显然得到了导游服务。我知道你喜欢导游服务，汤姆。我喜欢导游服务。是的。他们得到了导游服务。特别是如果这是来自皇帝本人。是的。嗯，我的意思是，他有令人惊叹的宫殿建筑群，在那里他会有他的记录，那种彩绘书籍。
There would be workshops. There would be fancy gardens. There would, Tom, be a zoo, which I imagine we will come back to in the second half. Yes. Yes. They play games with him so there's a story about a game they play called totolocke where basically you throw little kind of pellets try and hit a gold bar gold bar i mean they must have loved seeing that and cortez's sort of comrade pedro de alvarado the story is that he offers to
会有作坊。会有精美的花园。会有，汤姆，一个动物园，我想我们会在下半场回到这一点。是的。是的。他们和他一起玩游戏，所以有一个关于他们玩的一种叫托托洛克（totolocke）的游戏的故事，基本上你扔一些小颗粒，试图击中金条，金条，我的意思是，他们一定很喜欢看到那个，科尔特斯的战友佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多，故事是他主动提出
keep the score as cortez plays the emperor but alvarado is a cheat he keeps inflating cortez's score because he wants the spanish to win that's not cricket and montezuma notices and says plays the emperor. But Alvarado is a cheat. He keeps inflating Cortés' score because he wants the Spanish to win. That's not cricket. And Montezuma notices and says, don't think I can't see
在科尔特斯和皇帝玩的时候记分，但阿尔瓦拉多是个骗子，他不断夸大科尔特斯的得分，因为他想让西班牙人赢，那不是板球精神，蒙特祖马注意到了，说，在玩皇帝。但阿尔瓦拉多是个骗子。他不断夸大科尔特斯的得分，因为他想让西班牙人赢。那不是板球精神。蒙特祖马注意到了，说，别以为我看不见
what you're doing. You're trying to cheat in this game. And there's also a story that the emperor took a shine to one of Cortés' page boys. I'm guessing it's probably a teenager
你在做什么。你试图在这个游戏中作弊。还有一个故事说，皇帝看中了科尔特斯的一名侍从。我猜他可能是一个十几岁的男孩
called Juan Orteguia. And he teaches him some Nahuatl and Orteguia tells him stories about life in Spain. Yeah, we have this thing called tapas. I see, that's what he said, Tom. Yeah.
叫胡安·奥尔特吉亚。他教了他一些纳瓦特尔语，奥尔特吉亚给他讲了关于西班牙生活的故事。是的，我们有一种东西叫塔帕斯（tapas）。我明白了，汤姆，他就是这么说的。
So I think that's very plausible. They also do have little sort of jaunts, don't they? They go kind of hawking and they go hunting. Well, I mean, Dominic, you go abroad, you want to go on a jaunt, don't you? You do. You want a guided tour and you want a jaunt. I know you love a jaunt. Well, I like a jaunt. I go abroad, you want to go on a jaunt, don't you? You do. You want a guided tour and you want a jaunt. I know you love a jaunt. Well, I like a jaunt.
所以我认为这非常可信。他们也确实有一些小小的短途旅行，不是吗？他们去猎鹰，去打猎。嗯，我的意思是，多米尼克，你去国外，你想去短途旅行，不是吗？你确实想。你想要导游服务，你想要短途旅行。我知道你喜欢短途旅行。嗯，我喜欢短途旅行。我去国外，你想去短途旅行，不是吗？你确实想。你想要导游服务，你想要短途旅行。我知道你喜欢短途旅行。嗯，我喜欢短途旅行。
I don't love a guided tour, Tom. I think that's where you and I, it's one of the great cleavages in the rest of history, isn't it? You love a guided tour. I don't really like guided tours because I like to do my own thing. Because you are the cat that walks alone. I am the cat, but I do like a day trip. And they do go on day trips to the sort of lakeshore and they go hunting and things.
我不喜欢导游服务，汤姆。我想这就是你和我之间，这是《历史的余味》中的巨大分歧之一，不是吗？你喜欢导游服务。我不太喜欢导游服务，因为我喜欢做我自己的事情。因为你是独来独往的猫。我是那只猫，但我确实喜欢一日游。他们确实去湖岸进行一日游，他们去打猎之类的。
And the most extraordinary thing, which historians are puzzled over is they undoubtedly build ships. So they show off that they can build these ships. He must have heard about their extraordinary naval technology, extraordinary to the Mexica. They build some ships with room for cannons and things. Now, is that them showing off or is that them doing a job for him? Well, so this is the question, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, basically, who is in control of who at this point? That's the key.
最非凡的事情，历史学家们对此感到困惑的是，他们无疑建造了船只。所以他们炫耀他们能建造这些船只。他一定听说过他们非凡的海军技术，对墨西加人来说是非凡的。他们建造了一些有大炮空间之类的船只。现在，这是他们在炫耀，还是他们在为他做一份工作？嗯，所以这就是问题所在，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，基本上，此时是谁在控制谁？这是关键。
Here's the thing. Is he their plaything or are they his? Are they his guests? Are they his prisoners? Is he their prisoner? This is the great... Or are they perhaps animals in his zoo, which is a brilliant recent theory that perhaps we should come to after the break when we discuss exactly who is exploiting who at this point. Very much debated.
事情是这样的。他是他们的玩物，还是他们是他的？他们是他的客人吗？他们是他的囚犯吗？他是他们的囚犯吗？这是伟大的……或者他们也许是他动物园里的动物，这是一个精彩的最新理论，也许我们应该在休息后讨论，当我们讨论此时到底是谁在剥削谁时。非常有争议。
So we will be back in a few minutes to discuss that. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
所以我们几分钟后回来讨论这个问题。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in Tenochtitlan with Moctezuma and Cortes. Dominic, before the break, we were discussing who exactly has the whip hand at this moment. Moctezuma, presumably, because he's the emperor, he's the ruler of a vast empire. But Cortes is a figure so alarming, I think, to Moctezuma that he hasn't done the obvious thing and tried to have the Spaniards killed. That's the dog that doesn't bark in the night, really. But I suppose you would say, Tom, why would he have them killed? In other words, to use your science fiction analogy, if aliens landed on our planet with tremendous technology,
前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们现在在特诺奇蒂特兰，和蒙特祖马与科尔特斯在一起。多米尼克，休息前，我们正在讨论此时到底是谁掌握着主动权。蒙特祖马，大概，因为他是皇帝，他是一个庞大帝国的统治者。但科尔特斯是一个让蒙特祖马感到如此惊恐的人物，我想，以至于他没有做显而易见的事情，试图杀死西班牙人。那真的是夜里不叫的狗。但我猜你会说，汤姆，他为什么要杀死他们？换句话说，用你的科幻类比，如果外星人带着惊人的技术降落在我们的星球上，
and there were 300 of them, and they arrived in Washington, DC or in London or Paris or whatever, would your instinct be to kill them? I think your instinct would be to treat them with extreme nervousness, to try and find out what their technology was, to find out exactly what they can do, how dangerous are they, and to try and work out how many more of them are lurking in the background. So in other words, if I kill all the aliens, is there an entire fleet of flying saucers waiting to come in? I mean, those would be the two things that I would want to do. And you were saying about how Cortez develops a ship. I mean, this is obviously of interest to Moctezuma, but it is also Cortez's way of demonstrating. If we can build a ship like
有300个，他们抵达了华盛顿特区或伦敦或巴黎之类的城市，你的本能会是杀死他们吗？我想你的本能会是极其紧张地对待他们，试图找出他们的技术是什么，找出他们到底能做什么，他们有多危险，并试图弄清楚还有多少人在背景中潜伏。所以换句话说，如果我杀死了所有的外星人，是否有一整支飞碟舰队在等待进入？我的意思是，那将是我想要做的两件事。你刚才说科尔特斯是如何开发一艘船的。我的意思是，这显然是蒙特祖马感兴趣的，但这也是科尔特斯展示的方式。如果我们能建造一艘像
this and think how many of us can come across the great ocean. Yeah, I think that's very plausible. I mean, I think another way of thinking about it is this. Imagine if people with 19th century technology had pitched up in 15th century England, the time of the Wars of the Roses. So a period we know a fair amount about. We know how people thought. We know what kind of assumptions Edward IV and Richard III and people like that had. Is it plausible that if Captain Cook or David Livingstone or General Gordon had arrived, that they would have been killed immediately? No. People would have been absolutely fascinated, as I'm sure the Mexica were.
这样的船，想想我们有多少人能跨越浩瀚的海洋。是的，我认为这非常可信。我的意思是，我认为另一种思考方式是这样的。想象一下，如果拥有19世纪技术的人出现在15世纪的英国，玫瑰战争时期。所以这是一个我们相当了解的时期。我们知道人们是怎么想的。我们知道爱德华四世和理查三世之类的人有什么样的假设。如果库克船长或大卫·利文斯通或戈登将军抵达，他们会被立即杀死，这可信吗？不。人们会绝对着迷，我相信墨西加人也是如此。
What I don't think is plausible is that the hosts in that situation just completely abased themselves and groveled. Now, that is the image that you get in the Spanish sources and in the kind of orthodox histories of the conquest of Mexico that so many of our listeners would have read probably when they were children or teenagers or something. Because this is the claim that Cortes makes, isn't it? Writing shortly after to the king, saying that Montezuma, the first thing he's done is essentially surrender his kingdom to the Spanish king. Yeah. So in Cortes' account, in the standard account,
我不认为可信的是，那种情况下的主人只是完全自贬和卑躬屈膝。现在，这就是你在西班牙史料和关于墨西哥征服的正统历史中得到的形象，我们许多听众可能在他们还是孩子或青少年时就读过。因为这就是科尔特斯提出的主张，不是吗？不久后写信给国王，说蒙特祖马，他做的第一件事基本上就是把他的王国投降给西班牙国王。是的。所以在科尔特斯的叙述中，在标准叙述中，
Montezuma surrendered his kingdom almost immediately, within hours of their arrival and said, I am the vassal of Charles V. My kingdom now belongs to you. And obviously this then was layered over with all the stuff about him thinking they're gods and all this business, which I think is clearly not true. And then in the standard account, quite soon they decide they'll actually take him prisoner and they hold him as a hostage for months and months and months. But weirdly, he carries on ruling the kingdom, but under their supervision. Right. And in the Spanish accounts, they will describe Montezuma going off and doing whatever he likes. And then suddenly you remember that he's meant to have been a prisoner and try and kind of offer explanations as to how, if he was a prisoner, he was going off on grand processions and things.
蒙特祖马几乎在他们抵达后的几小时内就投降了他的王国，并说，我是查理五世的附庸。我的王国现在属于你了。显然，这随后被蒙上了一层关于他认为他们是神之类的所有东西，我认为这显然不是真的。然后按照标准叙述，很快他们决定实际上把他作为囚犯，他们把他作为人质关押了几个月又几个月。但奇怪的是，他继续统治王国，但在他们的监督下。对。而在西班牙的叙述中，他们会描述蒙特祖马出去做他喜欢的任何事情。然后突然你记得他本应是囚犯，并试图提供解释，如果他是囚犯，他是如何去参加盛大的游行之类的。
They keep forgetting their story. Right. Exactly. So when they're going on the day trips, they say, one day we decided to go hunting with hunting with montezuma he assembled all his men we went off he was of course still our prisoner yeah and i mean the historian who really destroys this is matthew restall in his brilliant brilliant book on the meeting between montezuma and cortez but even before that it was inherently implausible idea that for months and months and months the people of tenochtitlan would just be so passive and traumatized and lacking in agency that they would just sort of plod along to the markets as though nothing had happened while their emperor was being held prisoner. It's true that the Spanish are well-armed. It's also true they had the Tlaxcalan allies.
他们不断忘记他们的故事。对。没错。所以当他们去一日游时，他们说，有一天我们决定去打猎，和蒙特祖马一起打猎，他召集了他所有的人，我们出发了，他当然还是我们的囚犯，是的，我的意思是，真正摧毁这一点的是马修·雷斯托在他关于蒙特祖马和科尔特斯会面的精彩绝伦的书中所写的，但即使在那之前，几个月又几个月，特诺奇蒂特兰的人民会如此被动、受创伤且缺乏能动性，以至于他们会像什么都没发生一样去市场，而他们的皇帝却被关押，这种想法本身就是不可信的。西班牙人装备精良是真的。他们有特拉斯卡拉盟友也是真的。
But I would assume that at some stage, the Tlaxcalans must have gone home. Yeah, because they're a very mysterious presence in the whole story we were talking about in the last episode. It's unclear what they're doing. There aren't thousands of them billeted in the city for months and months and months. There's no reference to that, actually, in the sources. So I think at some point they must have gone home. The Spanish, of course, they're formidable. But, you know, if the Wagner group descended on London, took Rishi Sunak hostage, and holed up in Whitehall, it's utterly implausible for nine months or something.
但我会假设在某个阶段，特拉斯卡拉人一定回家了。是的，因为他们在整个故事中是一个非常神秘的存在，我们在上一集中谈到过。不清楚他们在做什么。并没有成千上万的人在城里驻扎几个月又几个月。实际上，史料中没有提到这一点。所以我认为在某个时候他们一定回家了。西班牙人，当然，他们很强大。但是，你知道，如果瓦格纳集团降临伦敦，劫持了里希·苏纳克，并躲在白厅，这九个月左右是完全不可信的。
Yeah, no attempt would be made to get him back. No attempt would be made to rescue him. There wouldn't be some uprising. I mean, it's just utterly unbelievable. So the question is, as the sort of new conquest historians say, the question is what is going on? And Matthew Restle has this absolutely fascinating argument that all the stories about them being Montezuma's guards and him being the prisoner is actually a massive exercise in projection. And that they really are his prisoners. And he has them under guard in that palace, that they are probably at his beck and call.
是的，不会有人试图把他救回来。不会有人试图营救他。不会有起义。我的意思是，这简直完全不可信。所以问题是，正如所谓的“新征服历史学家”所说，问题是发生了什么？马修·雷斯托有一个绝对迷人的论点，即所有关于他们是蒙特祖马的守卫、他是囚犯的故事，实际上是一个巨大的投射练习。他们实际上是他的囚犯。他把他们关在那座宫殿里，他们可能随叫随到。
And that's because he has a very, very specific fate in mind for them. Because we mentioned that one of the things he showed them was his zoo. And Montezuma is very unusual in having a zoo at all, because European monarchs didn't have zoos. Is that right, Tom? So we talked about this, I think, in a previous episode about the zoo in the Tower of London, and zoo very loosely. They have wild animals there. But Moctezuma's appetite for collecting seems to have been on an order that would be familiar, say, to Pliny the Elder, or to the authors of the Encyclopedia Britannica, or even to Wikipedia. We've talked about this before, how great empires often express their sense of their universal purpose and destiny with a mania for collecting and tabulating and constructing encyclopedias, or even better, constructing great museums or zoos. This is what Moctezuma is evidently doing. It's such a brilliant theory. that he was reading a thesis by a mexican scholar so it hadn't been translated into english and this was all about dr zuma and his mania for collecting and he was so impressed by it that he got in touch
那是因为他为他们想到了一个非常、非常具体的命运。因为我们提到他向他们展示的东西之一是他的动物园。蒙特祖马在拥有动物园方面非常独特，因为欧洲君主没有动物园。是这样吗，汤姆？所以我们谈到了这一点，我想在之前关于伦敦塔动物园的一集中，动物园非常松散。他们有野生动物在那里。但蒙特祖马收集的胃口似乎达到了一个程度，比如老普林尼，或《大英百科全书》的作者，甚至维基百科都会熟悉的程度。我们之前谈到过这一点，伟大的帝国通常如何通过对收集、制表和构建百科全书的狂热，或者更好的是，构建伟大的博物馆或动物园，来表达他们对普遍目的和命运的感知。这就是蒙特祖马显然在做的事情。这是一个如此精彩的理论。他正在阅读一位墨西哥学者的论文，所以它没有被翻译成英文，这全是关于祖马博士和他对收集的狂热，他对此印象深刻，以至于他联系了
with the scholar and then married her so yeah wow that's a lovely detail yeah great detail isn't it that's very summerton man that's what happened in the summerton man story isn't it the investigator married one of them yes to a degree to a degree um so that will mean nothing to people who haven't heard tom's brilliant brilliant true crime podcast about the greatest mystery in australian history i think it's fair to say tom yes so montezuma zoo there's a royal judge later on a spanish judge called alonzo zuazo and he spoke to the conquistadors and he later recorded montezuma had for show a house in which he had a great diversity of serpents and wild animals, which included tigers, bears, lions.
那位学者，然后娶了她，所以是的，哇，那是一个可爱的细节，是的，伟大的细节，不是吗，那非常像萨默顿人，这就是萨默顿人故事中发生的事情，不是吗，调查员娶了其中一个人，是的，在某种程度上，在某种程度上，嗯，所以这对没听过汤姆关于澳大利亚历史上最大谜团的精彩绝伦的真实犯罪播客的人来说毫无意义，我想说这是公平的，汤姆，是的，所以蒙特祖马的动物园，后来有一位皇家法官，一位叫阿隆佐·苏阿佐的西班牙法官，他与征服者交谈，他后来记录道，蒙特祖马为了展示，有一座房子，里面有各种各样的蛇和野生动物，包括老虎、熊、狮子。
By the way, spoiler, he definitely didn't have tigers and lions, did he, Tom? No. Wild boar, vipers, rattlesnakes, toads, frogs, many other snakes and birds, right down to worms. And each one of these things was in its place and in cages as needed. So that's the classification mania, Tom, with people assigned to give them food and all that was necessary to take care of them. Now, here's the interesting thing. He also had other people that were monstrous, such as dwarves and hunchbacks, some with one arm and others that were missing a leg, and other monstrous races that are born as such. So in other words, like so many monarchs,
顺便剧透一下，他肯定没有老虎和狮子，对吧，汤姆？没有。野猪、蝰蛇、响尾蛇、蟾蜍、青蛙，还有许多其他的蛇和鸟类，甚至还有蠕虫。每一样东西都各就各位，需要时就关在笼子里。这就是那种分类狂热，汤姆，还有专人负责喂食和照料它们。现在，有趣的事情来了。他还养了一些畸形人，比如侏儒和驼背，有的缺胳膊，有的少条腿，还有其他天生如此的畸形种族。换句话说，就像许多君主一样，
like Peter the Great or something, Montezuma is fascinated by people who are different. So the hunchbacks or whatever. And as Matthew Restle says, it's perfectly plausible that an emperor who wants to collect everything, because that will show he has power, he has dominion over flora, fauna, and all the different peoples.
比如彼得大帝之类的，蒙特祖马对与众不同的人非常着迷。所以那些驼背什么的。正如马修·雷斯特尔所说，一个想要收集万物的皇帝，这完全说得通，因为这能显示他的权力，显示他对动植物以及所有不同民族的统治力。
Yeah, it's the same thing as beasts in the arena in Rome. Yeah. It's a display of the global reach of the emperor. It's perfectly plausible that he would see the arrival of these extraordinary new people as a chance to add to his collection. I mean, he's obviously not going to stick them in cages, you know, like they're at Chester Zoo or something, but it's telling that the place where he houses them, the Palace of Aksaya Castle, is very close to the zoo complex. So he might be
是的，这和罗马竞技场里的野兽是一回事。没错。这是皇帝全球影响力的展示。他把这些非凡的新人视为扩充收藏品的机会，这完全说得通。我的意思是，他显然不会把他们关进笼子里，你知道，就像在切斯特动物园那样，但值得注意的是，他安置他们的地方，阿克萨亚卡特尔宫，离动物园建筑群非常近。所以他可能
sort of thinking, well, it would be great to have this addition, these people who work for me, who are my playthings. And also the fact they're armed, they're technologically adept. He might also be thinking they make great bodyguards. But he's clearly never watched Jurassic Park. Spanish Park, Conquistador Park. Yeah. I mean, if that's what he's doing and he thinks that he can keep them safely in their complex, I mean, obviously they're going to break out and run amok. But the thought that they would become a kind of elite guard. See, I'm reminded of Roman Empress, Tom Caligula. He had a group called the Germans, didn't he? The Batavians. Yeah, they were Batavians. And the Varangians in
在想，嗯，如果能有这些新成员，这些为我工作、作为我玩物的人，那该多好。而且他们还装备精良，技术娴熟。他可能还在想，他们会是很好的保镖。但他显然没看过《侏罗纪公园》。《西班牙公园》，《征服者公园》。是啊。我的意思是，如果他真的这么做，还以为能把他们安全地关在建筑群里，那他们显然会逃出来大闹一场。但认为他们会成为某种精锐卫队的想法……这让我想起了罗马皇帝，汤姆，卡里古拉。他有一群被称为“日耳曼人”的卫队，不是吗？巴达维亚人。对，他们是巴达维亚人。还有君士坦丁堡的瓦兰吉卫队。
Constantinople. Well, we've done podcasts about Baghdad, haven't we? So the Abbasid caliphate, they employed slave soldiers as an elite guard. The Mamlu, you know, in Egypt. And this, of course, is what the Tlaxcalans are after as well. I mean, I guess kind of competitive tendering. Yeah. Whoever can get the Spaniards on their side. But obviously, from Moctezuma's point of view, they have to be subordinate to him. And that is not at all what the Spaniards think. So there's an inherent tension there. Yes. Because they behave badly, I think it's fair to say. The Spaniards. Yeah. I mean, I'm guessing that these months are a process of both sides trying
我们做过关于巴格达的播客，不是吗？阿拔斯王朝，他们雇佣奴隶士兵作为精锐卫队。埃及的马穆鲁克。当然，这也是特拉斯卡拉人所追求的。我想这算是一种竞争性招标吧。谁能把西班牙人拉拢到自己这边。但显然，从蒙特祖马的角度来看，他们必须服从于他。而西班牙人根本不是这么想的。所以这里存在一种内在的紧张关系。是的。因为我觉得公平地说，他们的行为很糟糕。西班牙人。是啊。我的意思是，我猜这几个月是双方都在试图
to work out what the measure is of the other. Yeah. But of course, the Spanish have come there. Most of them, we used the phrase before, Matthew Restle's phrase, armed entrepreneurs. Most of them have come to make money. That's what they're doing. It's a great adventure, but they're there in the long run to get money, to get gold, to improve their status and that of their family and their clan and their patronage network and whatever. And over time, you can well imagine people saying to Cortes, what's going on here? We've been here like two and a half months and enough of the kind of going and hawking with the emperor. When are we going to get the gold and go back?
摸清对方底细的过程。是的。但当然，西班牙人来到这里。他们大多数人，我们之前用过那个词，马修·雷斯特尔的词，武装企业家。他们大多数人是为了赚钱而来。这就是他们的目的。这是一场伟大的冒险，但从长远来看，他们是为了钱，为了黄金，为了提升自己、家族、氏族和赞助网络的地位。随着时间的推移，你可以想象人们会对科尔特斯说，这到底是怎么回事？我们在这儿都待了两个半月了，和皇帝那种虚与委蛇也够了。我们什么时候能拿到黄金然后回去？
And there are stories, first of all, that Cortes is constantly pestering Montezuma for more gold, but also stories that some of the Spanish behave badly, that they don't stay in their cage, as it were. They roam out through the kind of palace complex. They will ransack rooms. They will basically steal fans and feathers and necklaces that they've been heaping up gold, and they've even started to melt it down. So there's an advisor in Montezlaces that they've been heaping up gold and they've even started to melt it down so there's an advisor montezuma who says they've been shouting and quarreling they seized the treasures as if they were their own like slaves they agreed they were laughing like like beasts actually that comparison with beasts perhaps gives you some sense of how some of
有传言说，科尔特斯不断地向蒙特祖马索要更多的黄金，也有传言说一些西班牙人的行为很糟糕，他们并没有待在自己的“笼子”里。他们在宫殿建筑群里四处游荡。他们会洗劫房间。他们基本上会偷走扇子、羽毛和项链，他们一直在堆积黄金，甚至已经开始熔化它。所以蒙特祖马的一位顾问说，他们一直在大喊大叫、争吵不休，他们像对待奴隶一样夺取财宝，他们像野兽一样大笑。实际上，那种与野兽的比较，或许让你感觉到蒙特祖马的一些
montezuma's people are thinking of them and cortez is already muttering about building ships and presumably he wants to build ships more ships because he knows he might be stopped on the causeway. It'd be very helpful for him to have ships to get across the lake. And then he's got to think about transporting the gold to the coast. So one obvious question would be, well, if the Spaniards are causing trouble, if they're clearly not going to be very good as exhibits in a zoo or even effectively employable as bodyguards, what do you do with them? And one obvious choice would be to sacrifice them or kill them or have them wiped out. And sacrificing them might be the best opportunity to keep the gods happy.
子民是如何看待他们的。科尔特斯已经在嘀咕着要造船了，大概他想造更多的船，因为他知道自己可能会在堤道上被拦截。有船能横渡湖泊对他来说会非常有帮助。然后他还得考虑把黄金运到海岸。所以一个显而易见的问题是，如果西班牙人惹是生非，如果他们显然不适合作为动物园的展品，甚至无法有效地作为保镖，那你该拿他们怎么办？一个显而易见的选择就是献祭他们，或者杀掉他们，或者把他们消灭掉。而献祭他们可能是让神灵高兴的最佳机会。
Oh, definitely. And it so happens, doesn't it, that winter is turning to spring and that brings a particular month having into view. And this month has the brilliant name of the flaying of men. Yes. I know you love this, Tom, because you were very keen when we had a World Cup of Gods. So for those people who think this is just babble, we organized a vote on Twitter and did some podcasts about which was the best god in human history. You were very keen to see the Mexica god Chibitotec thrive. Our lord, the flayed one. He crashed out in the first round, I'm afraid.
哦，绝对是。而且恰好，冬天转为春天，这带来了一个特殊的月份。这个月有一个响亮的名字：剥皮月。是的。我知道你喜欢这个，汤姆，因为我们在举办“诸神世界杯”时你非常热衷。所以对于那些认为这只是胡言乱语的人，我们在推特上组织了一次投票，并做了一些关于人类历史上最伟大神灵的播客。你非常热衷于看到墨西加神希佩·托特克大放异彩。我们的主，剥皮之主。恐怕他在第一轮就出局了。
He did very poorly. For reasons that may have to do with the general vibe that surrounds his cult. So basically, he's the god of fertility and he flays himself to give food to humanity. And there's this idea of life growing out of the flayed body, which you can kind of see the point of. But I think to our non-Meshika way of thinking, I think Chippy is the most terrifying of all the gods. And the festival that's celebrated during the month of the flaying of men, which marks the spring equinox, the Meshika would get prisoners and they would fight the equivalent of kind of gladiatorial combat. I mean, they would have a chance of winning, which marks the spring equinox, the Mashika would get prisoners and they would fight the equivalent of gladiatorial combat.
他表现得很差。原因可能与围绕他崇拜的总体氛围有关。基本上，他是丰收之神，他剥下自己的皮来供养人类。有一种生命从剥下的躯体中生长出来的概念，你可以理解其中的逻辑。但我认为，对于我们非墨西加人的思维方式来说，我认为希佩是最可怕的神。在剥皮月期间庆祝的节日，标志着春分，墨西加人会抓来俘虏，让他们进行类似于角斗士的战斗。我的意思是，他们会有获胜的机会，
They would have a chance of winning, of surviving, but the odds are massively, massively against them. And effectively, this is a form of ritualized execution. The bodies then get skinned and the priests of Chibi then wear the flayed skins as kind of cloaks for the following 20 days. And it's a kind of terrifying trick and treat that they're going around with these flayed skins. And it's all part of the fun of the festival is that they're kind of entering houses and demanding gifts and arms and presents from people for the love of Chippy Totec. And then when the festival
他们会有获胜、生存的机会，但胜算极其极其渺茫。实际上，这是一种仪式化的处决。尸体随后会被剥皮，希佩的祭司们会在接下来的20天里穿着剥下的皮作为斗篷。这是一种可怕的“不给糖就捣蛋”，他们穿着这些剥下的皮到处走动。节日乐趣的一部分就是他们会进入人们的家中，以希佩·托特克的名义索要礼物、施舍和馈赠。然后当节日
is over, the flayed skins are removed and they're put into special stone containers with very tight fitting lids. And the aim of these lids is to stop the stench of putrefaction from wafting away. And then they're stored beneath the temple. And I think it's very difficult, no matter how open you are to celebrating the diversity of human cultures across the world, not to feel that this is an unsettling way of marking a festival. It is, isn't it? So I love the trick-or-treating detail and i also love there's another detail because there are different accounts of how this worked there's another detail that as people pitched up wearing wearing the flayed skin of the uh and also also stabbing their penises with thorns that's also part of the fun yes there is that element when
结束时，剥下的皮会被取下，放入带有紧密盖子的特殊石制容器中。这些盖子的目的是防止腐烂的恶臭飘散出来。然后它们被存放在神庙下方。我认为，无论你对庆祝世界各地多元文化有多么开放，都很难不觉得这是一种令人不安的节日纪念方式。确实是这样，不是吗？所以我喜欢“不给糖就捣蛋”的细节，我也喜欢另一个细节，因为关于它是如何运作的有不同的说法，还有一个细节是，当人们穿着剥下的皮，并且用荆棘刺穿自己的阴茎时，这也是乐趣的一部分。是的，确实有那个元素，当
they would pitch up families would bring their children to come and come and hug them so yeah people will be delighted to hear that in my children's book the fall of the aztecs When they would pitch up, families would bring their children to come and hug them. So people will be delighted to hear that in my children's book, The Fall of the Aztecs, there was a long section. Of course there is. Discussing this. And my editor said to me, kind of raised his eyebrows, if you can raise your eyebrows digitally on an email, and said, really, for children? And I said, listen, if you've ever met a child, a 10-year-old or 11-year-old child.
他们出现时，家庭会带着孩子去拥抱他们。所以，人们会很高兴听到，在我的童书《阿兹特克帝国的陨落》中，有一大段内容。当然有。讨论了这个。我的编辑对我挑了挑眉毛，如果你能在电子邮件里数字化地挑眉毛的话，他说，真的吗，给孩子看？我说，听着，如果你见过孩子，10岁或11岁的孩子。
Well, this is one of the things I remember from reading about the Aztecs as a child. The whole wearing a flayed skin, snapping your penis with a thorn, eye-opening stuff. Frankly, this is the true spirit of Halloween, isn't it? It's been lost. It really is. It really is. So anyway, Matthew Restle argues, and of course so much of this is supposition, speculation. He says, would it not have made sense for the Aztecs to be thinking, this is the time, this is the way we get rid of the Spaniards? That perhaps they've been sent by Chippy.
嗯，这是我小时候读阿兹特克历史时记得的事情之一。整个穿着剥下的皮，用荆棘刺穿阴茎，真是大开眼界。坦率地说，这才是万圣节的真正精神，不是吗？它已经失传了。确实如此。确实如此。所以无论如何，马修·雷斯特尔认为，当然其中很多是假设和推测。他说，阿兹特克人认为“这是时候了，这是我们摆脱西班牙人的方式”，这难道不合理吗？也许他们是被希佩派来的。
Yeah, because it also comes at the end of their hunting season, I think. Yeah, very serendipitous, the timing. Everything, that it just feels like the perfect solution. However, now there is a massive twist. Because at some point, late April, early May, at the point at which Montezuma could well have been thinking, okay, now these wild beasts are out of control, it's time to get rid of them and'm bored of them now at that point he clearly gets word from the coast that something unexpected has happened more strangers have arrived 18 ships near the town of vera cruz the town founded by cortez carrying more than a thousand
是的，因为它也正好赶在他们的狩猎季节结束时，我想。是的，时机非常巧合。一切都感觉像是完美的解决方案。然而，现在有一个巨大的转折。因为在某个时候，四月下旬或五月上旬，在蒙特祖马很可能已经在想“好吧，现在这些野兽失控了，是时候摆脱他们了，我已经厌倦他们了”的时候，他显然从海岸得到了消息，发生了意想不到的事情：更多的陌生人到达了。在科尔特斯建立的韦拉克鲁斯镇附近有18艘船，载着一千多名
men that the strangers are the same they have red hair, what seems to the Aztecs reddish hair. They have pale skins. It seems beyond doubt that Montezuma hears about this before Cortes does. And he is almost certainly sending agents to talk to these newcomers and to say, who are you? What is going on? And clearly he finds out they have not come as allies of cortez they have actually come to apprehend him this is a i mean we'll save the full explanation for this for the
人。这些陌生人是一样的，他们有红头发，在阿兹特克人看来是红色的头发。他们皮肤苍白。毫无疑问，蒙特祖马在科尔特斯之前就听说了这件事。而且他几乎肯定派了代理人去和这些新来者交谈，问他们：“你们是谁？发生了什么事？”显然他发现他们并不是作为科尔特斯的盟友来的，他们实际上是来逮捕他的。这是一个……我的意思是，我们将把完整的解释留到
next episode tom because it's so exciting but this for montezuma this really is a game changer because he sends for cortez and he says to him i know you're thinking about building new ships and getting home and all this there is no need your friends have arrived on the coast. You can go home without delay to Spain. It was lovely to see you. Goodbye. And for Cortez, this is a terrible moment because he doesn't know who the newcomers are, but remember, he had disobeyed his orders. He had taken this massive chance and he must at that point have had a strong suspicion. They had been sent by Diego Velazquez, the governor of Cuba, the guy whose orders he had disobeyed.
下一集，汤姆，因为它太令人兴奋了。但对于蒙特祖马来说，这确实是一个转折点。因为他派人叫来科尔特斯，对他说：“我知道你在考虑造新船回家之类的，没必要了。你的朋友已经到达海岸了。你可以立即回西班牙了。很高兴见到你。再见。”对于科尔特斯来说，这是一个可怕的时刻，因为他不知道这些新来者是谁，但请记住，他违抗了命令。他冒了这么大的险，此时他一定强烈怀疑他们是古巴总督迭戈·贝拉斯克斯派来的，也就是那个他违抗了命令的人。
He had sailed off in full view of Velazquez when he was being told to stay. And this is awful. This is a terrible turning point in the story for Cortez. And for a few days, he does nothing. And then he summons the big wigs, the big cheeses from his company. And he says, what on earth are we going to do about this? And supposedly, he ends the meeting by saying, listen, we're in too deep now. We have to just, we're going to have to kill them.
他在贝拉斯克斯的眼皮底下航行离开，当时他被告知要留下。这太糟糕了。这是科尔特斯故事中一个可怕的转折点。几天来，他什么也没做。然后他召集了公司里的大人物、大老板。他说：“我们到底该怎么办？”据推测，他以这样的话结束了会议：“听着，我们现在陷得太深了。我们必须……我们不得不杀了他们。”
We're going to have to get rid. We're going to have to get rid of them. Death to all who oppose us. Now, the thing is, Tom, he doesn't have many men because I'm guessing people have deserted. Some people have died of disease. Been killed in brawls. Killed in brawls. So he's probably got about 200 men in Tenochtitlan left. The Tlaxcalans just don't seem to be in the picture at all at this point. So what he does is he divides his company. He says, I'm taking Malinche and I'll take about 80 men.
“我们必须摆脱他们。反对我们的人都得死。”现在的问题是，汤姆，他没有多少人，因为我猜有人逃跑了。有些人死于疾病。在斗殴中被杀。在斗殴中被杀。所以他在特诺奇蒂特兰可能只剩下大约200人了。特拉斯卡拉人此时似乎根本不在画面中。所以他所做的是拆分了他的公司。他说，我带着马林切，带上大约80人。
The rest will stay and he's going to leave them under Pedro de Alvarado to stay in the capital. And there is a theory among some more recent historians, Matthew Restle, Camilla Townsend, for example, disagreeing with more orthodox historians like Hugh Thomas and Fernando Cervantes, that it's at this point that he thinks, okay- In for a penny, in for a pound. Yeah. Yeah.
其余的人将留下，他将把他们留在佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多的指挥下留在首都。一些较新的历史学家，例如马修·雷斯特尔、卡米拉·汤森，与休·托马斯和费尔南多·塞万提斯等更传统的历史学家持不同意见，他们认为就在这时他想：“好吧，既然已经开始了，就得干到底。”是的。
Let's do this. I've got to move against Montezuma. So this is April, May 1520. I think it's at this point that he takes Montezuma hostage. He's often gone in to see Montezuma. Bernadier says this happened in the autumn. I don't think it did. I think it happened now. But I think the details of Bernadier's account are perfectly plausible. chief officers alvarado sandoval lugo leon and abila and our interpreters alinche and geronimo d'aguilar who's still hanging around though increasingly redundant and they were armed they're carrying weapons but bernal diaz says we'd always carried weapons when we visited montezuma so he won't think this is untoward and cortez says to him we want you to follow us now to our palace we will treat you with respect but if you make any alarm or if you call out to your attendants you are a dead man and montezuma says there's no way
干吧。我必须对蒙特祖马采取行动。所以这是1520年的四月或五月。我认为就在这时他扣押了蒙特祖马。他经常去见蒙特祖马。贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯说这发生在秋天。我不这么认为。我认为是现在发生的。但我认为贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯描述的细节是完全合理的。首席军官阿尔瓦拉多、桑多瓦尔、卢戈、莱昂和阿维拉，还有我们的翻译马林切和杰罗尼莫·德·阿吉拉尔，他还在那里，尽管越来越没用。他们全副武装，带着武器，但贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯说：“我们拜访蒙特祖马时总是带着武器。”所以他不会认为这有什么不妥。科尔特斯对他说：“我们现在要你跟我们去我们的宫殿。我们会尊重你，但如果你发出任何警报，或者如果你呼唤你的侍从，你就死定了。”蒙特祖马说：“我绝不会
i'm going with you and then they have an argument which goes on and on for some time clearly he's he's so complacent at this point that he's not surrounded by guards or they have somehow been dealt with and then one of the conquistadors ju Juan Velázquez de León, says, what's the use of throwing away so many words? He must either quietly follow us or we will cut him down at once. Be so good as to tell him this. This must be to Malinche. For on this depends the safety of our lives.
跟你们走。”然后他们争论了很长一段时间。显然，他此时太自满了，以至于他身边没有守卫，或者他们以某种方式被处理掉了。然后其中一名征服者，胡安·贝拉斯克斯·德·莱昂说：“浪费这么多口舌有什么用？他要么安静地跟我们走，要么我们立刻砍了他。最好告诉他这一点。”这一定是告诉马林切的。“因为我们的生命安全取决于此。”
We must show determination or we are inevitably lost. And Malinche doesn't quite translate this, though it's obvious to Montezuma that this guy is waving a sword at him. Malinche says, Great King, I advise you, go with them. They will treat you with respect. They will treat you with courtesy.
“我们必须表现出决心，否则我们必死无疑。”马林切并没有完全翻译这句话，尽管蒙特祖马很清楚这家伙在对他挥舞剑。马林切说：“伟大的国王，我建议您，跟他们走吧。他们会尊重您的。他们会以礼相待。”
But if you refuse, they will kill you. And he goes. He says to his servants, I'm actually going to go over there with these guys to their palace and visit them. And people are clearly stunned, but they don't dare to question the emperor. So he is installed in the palace. I would imagine probably, Tom, I think it seems plausible that they're not beating him or tying him up or something.
“但如果您拒绝，他们会杀了您。”于是他走了。他对仆人说：“我实际上要和这些人去他们的宫殿拜访他们。”人们显然惊呆了，但他们不敢质疑皇帝。于是他被安置在宫殿里。我想，汤姆，我认为他们没有殴打他或绑住他之类的，这似乎是合理的。
No, no, because if they were, then that would obviously raise the suspicions of the millions of his subjects who are kind of just waiting to pile in. And I guess that the difference between Varangians serving an emperor and an emperor who is the prisoner of the Varangians is not immediately obvious. No, not if they're still bowing and treating him with courtesy and whatnot. And of course, they have the weapons. They carry them at all times, the steel swords that the Aztecs cannot compete with. But you know, what a double gamble. What a double gamble. It's not enough to decide that Cortes is going to divide his forces, which you should never do, and go off with a party to confront another group of Spaniards who massively, massively outnumber them. But at the same time, to take the emperor of the Mexica hostage.
不，不，因为如果他们那样做了，那显然会引起他数百万臣民的怀疑，他们正等着一拥而上。我想，瓦兰吉卫队侍奉皇帝与皇帝成为瓦兰吉卫队的囚犯之间的区别，并不是那么显而易见。不，如果他们仍然鞠躬并以礼相待的话。当然，他们有武器，他们随时携带武器，那是阿兹特克人无法抗衡的钢剑。但是，你知道，这是一场双重赌博。这是一场双重赌博。仅仅决定科尔特斯要分兵（这是永远不应该做的），并带一队人去对抗另一群人数远超他们的西班牙人是不够的。同时还要扣押墨西加皇帝作为人质。
I know. I mean, these are two lunatic gambles. But what choice does he have? I mean, you can just imagine, he's off going down the causeway and absolutely everything hangs in the balance at this point. He's done the one thing I think that nobody expected. And he's going off to the coast with only 80 men, leaving the rest behind with Montezuma.
我知道。我的意思是，这是两场疯狂的赌博。但他有什么选择呢？我的意思是，你可以想象，他正沿着堤道走，此时一切都悬而未决。他做了我认为没人预料到的那件事。他只带了80人前往海岸，把其余的人留在了蒙特祖马身边。
He's going off to the coast with only 80 men, leaving the rest behind with Montezuma. He's going through this alien landscape to fight his own people. Everything hangs in the balance. Yeah. I mean, it's one of the most extraordinary punts in history. And I think we should stop this episode here. And when we come back, we will look at what the upshot of these two extraordinary punts are. Cortés going off to confront his fellow Spaniards by Veracruz on the coast and the capture of Moctezuma and the taking of him as hostage by the Spaniards who remain in Tenochtitlan.
他只带了80人前往海岸，把其余的人留在了蒙特祖马身边。他穿过这片陌生的土地去对抗自己的人。一切都悬而未决。是的。我的意思是，这是历史上最非凡的豪赌之一。我想我们应该在这里结束这一集。当我们回来时，我们将看看这两场非凡豪赌的结果。科尔特斯前往海岸对抗他的西班牙同胞，以及西班牙人扣押蒙特祖马作为人质，而他们留在特诺奇蒂特兰。
So absolute scenes. What a cliffhanger, Tom. Absolute cliffhanger. We will be back next week. But not for everybody. Unless, Dominic. Yeah. Unless you are a member of
真是绝对的场面。真是悬念重重，汤姆。绝对的悬念。我们下周回来。但不是对所有人。除非，多米尼克。是的。除非你是
the rest is history club in which case you can go in here the remaining four episodes find out what happens resolve this incredible cliffhanger so the choice is yours but either way we will see you back very soon for episode five bye I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
“Rest Is History”俱乐部的成员，那样的话你可以进去听剩下的四集，找出发生了什么，解开这个不可思议的悬念。所以选择权在你，但无论如何，我们很快就会在第五集见到你。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐即历史》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请前往……目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。